Alright folks, welcome back. This is episode 29. I'm going to be doing a brief review of
what took place today. I obviously executed today. I wasn't planning on doing two videos
but obviously by the comments some people are a little bit confused. So I kind of want
to bring your attention back to that 12,553 and a quarter level, which is the relative
equal highs here on NASDAQ. So that was kind of like the basis for why I went into the
market today, Monday, the 16th of May, 2022, the bullish bias. I was looking for this draw
on liquidity still for NASDAQ. I originally went in looking for a trade in NASDAQ but
the S&P, much like the NASDAQ, had a daily swing low. While we didn't have relative
equal highs here for S&P, the bias was, in my opinion, warranted for at least the beginning
of the week, looking for a continuation on the upside. Before I get into it tomorrow,
which is Tuesday, May 17, 2022, 8.30 in the morning New York local time, we have retail
sales numbers and then two o'clock in the afternoon New York local time, we have the
Fed Chairman speaking. So there's going to be all kinds of volatility at two o'clock
tomorrow. That's the reason why the market was kind of like lethargic today but I wanted
to kind of like showcase something. So today I kind of like want to put a nail in the coffin
finally about this whole business about rented NT4 servers. Okay, I'm never going to bring
the conversation up again or the topic again. I think everyone knows now by seeing what
I've done here just in a short span of time. If I did this for another five, six weeks,
you could clearly see that it's not impossible for the same things I was doing on Twitter
years and years ago, okay, with MT4. I'm not using MT4 here. I can't game the system. I'm
using live data. You're watching me execute. It is what it is, folks. Okay, now it's paper
trading, it's demo trading, but I do it just to prove that I can read this stuff. I'm not
trying to beat my chest. I'm not trying to brag, but I just want to finally put this to bed because
it's still, you see people talking all the time. When they do that kind of talking, you take them
back to these videos here. You link these videos to them and let them choke on it. All right,
so we have the one minute chart. I went right into the one minute chart because we're starting
with the bullish bias and at 930 we see the market does in fact take out a short-term high. It
declines. I'm not interested in going short. It does not give me a pattern anyway. Notice that
there's no fair value gap revisited. The market creates this relative equal low, starts a rally,
trades up into the afternoon in here. I want to see it create a buying opportunity. Now,
the logic behind all this is we're in a day before Fed Chair speaks. There's going to be
very low volatility as a result of that. It's going to be a small range day. It doesn't mean
you can't trade it, obviously, but it takes a little bit more experience. Now, I'm not saying
that you should trade ahead of Fed Chair Powell speaking or any future Fed Chairman because it's
going to be a very quiet day usually like this. It's important to know when the volatility is
likely to occur and when also the volatility is likely to shrink up and get kind of like lethargic.
If you look at the S&P at the top, you see the drop down relative equal lows and then we have
the same similar pattern here, but look what Nasdaq was doing. See that? Low or low when S&P was
saying, I don't want to go that low. So it was resisting going lower. Then we retraced higher,
just like this Nasdaq did, but then Nasdaq made a lower low than that of 10 o'clock in the morning.
While at the same time, the S&P said, no, once again, I'm not going lower than the low I made
at 10 o'clock. So we had a divergence here and here. No indicators, folks. I'm using
intermarket relationships and this is what I dubbed SMT, smart money technique or a smart
money tool. Now, the importance of that is I already had a bias that's bullish. There was no
short trades that were lined up with this model today. There was no interest in wanting to be
short. I want to focus on being long. So we're in the one minute chart here and I want you to take
a look at what we have framework wise. Obviously, you've probably already seen the short video
compressed today, but looking at price action like this, yes, you can see there is a rally up. It
breaks the short-term low, a fair value gap. It trades up into it and breaks down. Big deal. This
doesn't fit the criteria because the displacement leg here would require us to see a fair value
gap above 50% of the high and the low, the displacement leg, and we don't have that. So
nothing here fits the model for a short, but watch what happens. The market creates a run
on sell stops here, then more rallies, retraces back down into a fair value gap. I seen this
happening, but I was trying to get the recording software that I use and by the way, let me just
throw this in here too because I see people asking. My website address as a watermark,
TradingView doesn't do that. I use my Camtasia recording software that helps me do these videos.
It's just an application you can overlay like a text call out, I call it, and that's what it is.
So it's really when I'm doing the recording talking, there is nothing here. It's a blank
chart and then at the end of the recording, when I'm editing it, I'll just add in my website
address. So anyway, with that said, we've seen the market trade back down in and I was trying to
get the Camtasia Studio to open up and sometimes it doesn't open up and give me what I need,
so I have to close it down entirely and restart it and the whole time this candle was doing its
business and I wanted to see it return into this fair value gap once more and I got in on this
candle here and we'll look at the relationship between the NASDAQ which was a little bit
sloppier in here versus the S&P, a little bit more structured here. So the fair value gap in here,
this candle in here, it wicks down into it and I want to get close to this fair value gap without
it running too far away. So I kind of want to touch a little bit tonight with close proximity
entries. That means you might not get so precise with your entries. You might fumble with your order
entry or something might happen like it happened with me. I wanted to record me entering, not just
simply say here, here's a trade I took. So I wanted to show obviously me getting in, putting a stop,
managing a position and adding the second position in here. What do you do in that situation if you
miss the idle entry? Well as long as you're getting in there really close or like I'm suggesting here
a close proximity entry, I don't think there's anything wrong with it. So if we are looking for
entry patterns, the idea is we want to get into where our model is suggesting it. So we're seeing
the market trade lower, lower, lower. It's failing to make a lower low like NASDAQ and we have this
low that's probably not going to be taken out because we're bullish. The market rallies up. We
have a short-term shift in market structure that trades back down into the fair value gap. Look how
many opportunities it gave to go long. One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight. Eight candles.
It gave an opportunity to get in this area here either inside the fair value gap or in close
proximity to it. Now when the market starts to rally, I have one more indication that the market
structure has shifted again bullish with these highs taken out here and then they had a small
little fair value gap there and then you watch me add more. A limit order came in, filled it,
only had one and three quarters handles. Seven ticks if you want to think of it like that. I had
seven ticks of heat against me on this little candle here before I started running in my favor.
I took the full pull off here and I did not get the highest high. I was a little disappointed in
that regard but the candle obviously hit it there and we'll go over to trading view and look at the
business. All right we're over here on trading view. This is live. You can see time that's
recording. This is where I'm sitting down with the computer and the market trades lower creates
that short-term run here. Rallies breaking market structure to the upside. Trades in the fair value
gap and the secondary fair value gap and it runs up into the liquidity above here. Now if I add
the executions I want you to see. Look right in here and right in here and up here where you'll
see the exits and entries respectively. So you can see there's that candle, that entry,
three thousand nine hundred ninety four and a half, three thousand nine hundred and ninety
six and a quarter and it went down to ninety four. What's the love here? Ninety four and a half. So
it was only less than two handles heat against me before I started rallying there. This one
thirty nine nine four fifty was right in here and the low on this candle ninety three and a quarter.
So one and a quarter, no less than one, less than one handle of heat entering on this candle here
and the next candle had a little bit of retracement. So very very very tight placement and this was not
entering in the fair value gap. It was in close proximity to it. So the underlying idea was it was
going down in here to go higher retrace into that to go higher and you saw me map all this stuff here
and call it up and you know business is done. But the exit up here four thousand twenty two and a half
and that's that. You can see there is no short positions in here, no short positions over here
on that business and on NASDAQ we'll pull that up just for completeness sake too.
Okay and no executions here. So all the business was done in the S&P today.
So my question to you is when you see these videos and I'm trying to illustrate obviously that I don't
need to fraud anyone. The things I'm teaching you I think that you're seeing evidence that it works.
Hopefully you guys have seen enough with this here. Do the math folks okay. In less than a week and a half
how much more would you see this compound if I did it for six more weeks or five weeks. Is it hard to imagine
the things that I did on Twitter with MT4, not a rent to MT4 server, literally pushing a button, putting
the orders in, doing the whole business okay. I know a lot of you have just discovered me and you're
seeing people post stuff about how other traders or other mentors or other teachers they fake their
positions. I'm open about paper trading because it's compliance. I'm not legally allowed to give you
trade advice. So I'm protected by my discussion in paper trading because you cannot make money
with paper trades and you can't lose money with paper trades. But I've always said this from the
beginning. I've dubbed myself the demo baller. I champion that name because I want to make sure
everyone knows that I'm not promising you profitability. I don't dangle a carrot in front of you and say
you're going to do what I'm doing here because you're not going to be able to replicate this.
You're not okay. Don't be deceived by seeing me do this again for like the fifth time. Running up
an account like this would break neck speed velocity and this is just casually doing it in a
tight range. When there's large ranges I could have easily taken this over to a million dollars
already. But it doesn't prove anything except for the fact that I can read price action. That's all.
That's all I'm showcasing. I'm not trying to say I'm the best. I'm not trying to say that you can't
make money in other things. I'm just saying I know how to read these candlesticks. I know what they're
likely to do most of the time before they do it. Not all the time. I take losing trades. But when
it's really likely to work with the algorithm I'll be dialed in. You can't fake what I'm doing. You
can see me executing the trade. You can see me managing the trade and you can see the orders
entering and filling. They pop up. They verify the whole thing. No replay button up here. None of
this stuff. See how that's blue now? You can't create that same scenario. I'm hopefully satisfying
this discussion that people like to bring up all the time about rented MT4 servers because they
couldn't wait to put that on me because they watched me do just like this and I ran up to
five million dollars in a little less than one and a half months. I understand that doesn't seem
possible. I understand that people that would be able to do what I'm doing could very easily go out
there and defraud people. I'm telling you it's demo. I'm not saying that I did that with real money.
I'm just saying that I can read price action. I can see these patterns forming and even with
these other folks out there with fake MT4 servers and MT4 screenshots of making money and all this
other fake withdrawals. I made fun of all that stuff. I trolled those people on Twitter. Now I'm
about to go back to Twitter. This time I'm not going there with that intent. I'm ready should
someone want to bring it but I'm not there or going there for that reason. The reason why I'm
going to Twitter is I miss being able to do my small little vignettes where I would do recordings
of me either taking a trade or reading price action and having some short little clip 40 seconds
long or less of music in the background. I miss doing that. Maybe it wasn't always your cup of tea
for my music choice but I have a very diverse palette for music and it's just one of those
things I enjoy doing. So it might not be worth it for you to follow me on Twitter or it might be.
But I kind of wanted to clear the air for the last time and show you all one more time where
I don't need to do what frauds do. I can see this stuff before it happens and you can learn
how to do this too. You can read it before it happens. You can see it. You can have faith
that the things that you're learning here are rooted on sound logic. It's not randomness. It's
not retail logic. These are things that are algorithmic and I think today was a testimony
to that. So tomorrow is going to be very volatile. Be careful. Do not try to trade tomorrow. You'll
probably hurt yourself if you do or don't listen to me and learn the lesson the hard way. Until
I talk to you next time, be safe.